[Music]
hello everybody watching e.t
this is our new video we want you to
check it out
this is our new incognito look you think
it'd work i think this gives new meaning
to plastic surgery
on this day in sync released their third
studio album
no strings attached the year was 2 000
and only e.t
was on the set of the music video for
their highly anticipated
second single it's gonna be me yes the
same song that turned
justin timberlake into the famous meme
we see every spring
it's gonna be may well we are here
today uh filming extra
b-roll vignette today footage
where we're actually inside the toy
store because that's the whole
setup of the video for it's going to be
me as is we're in a toy store
we shot all the performance scenes
yesterday so you're just going gonna
have to wait to see them
jt jc chazzay joey fatone
lance bass and chris kirkpatrick all
transformed into an animated plastic
doll version of themselves
and surprise it was a long makeup
process for the famous boy band
yeah it's a lot of fun we've been in
we're in makeup for like
four hours and uh it was
it was it's worth it though i mean it's
gonna come off good on camera
the glue fumes are getting to our brain
really delirious right now i think
lansing or joey
originally came with a concept and once
you know somebody comes up with a
concept for a video we ought to start
rolling with ideas
it's gonna be may well basically it's a
domino thing and we knocked down some
dominoes and
another dominoes start heading towards
us so we run out of way before it hits
us
[Music]
[Applause]
the music video for it's gonna be me
made its debut on total requests live in
may
and have the top position until
september that year
and the hit song was the only one of in
syncs to peek at number one on the
billboard charts
i think the next thing you'll see us
doing is no strings attached world tour
the band no strings attached world tour
completely sold out the first day of
sale
we were in japan they were in japan
whenever about it we freaked out
this is exciting so clive now you can
give us like land rovers for christmas
or something
we're gonna get on our stage in a matter
in like three or four days for the first
time
the first time so yeah it's gonna be
exciting we're a little nervous but
hey man it's gonna be a good time it's
gonna be a lot of hard work
at the time the tour became the second
highest grossing tour in america
earning more than 70 million dollars
[Music]
in sync's no strings attached album went
on to sell 2.4 million copies in the
first week of its release
eventually making the group one of the
best-selling boy bands in music history
we were just excited that this was our
first number one album
you know and now it's been what like
five weeks straight number one
it's kind of like you know if you can
believe it you can do it and that's kind
of the attitude we've taken on lately
it's just like
if we can see it in our heads we feel
like we can make it happen
gonna be may